I'm sure you're kind of following what's
going on with uh what he called it
musk's recent hire the CEO yeah uh some
are happy about it some are concerned
World economic forum
you know is he going this direction is
he going that direction he does an
interview the next day the guy asked the
question I don't know if you've seen
this or not where there's a 10 second
pause can you pull this up where he says
I'll say whatever I want to say Great
Clips
what do you what do you what's the what
title should he put to find this clip
with a 10 second uh I do what I want a a
musk
you know which one I'm talking about I
think that one there can you zoom in a
little bit to see if you see the how
long is that two minutes and 40s no
don't do that one because you're gonna
have to find the 10 second clip maybe in
the search put 10 seconds
in the search for 10 seconds for this to
come up 10 seconds to come up uh okay
well you look forward I want to ask
Tulsi Tulsi what do you think about the
higher of his recent CEO I think her
name is I want to say Linda uh what are
your thoughts on the recent CEO hire
I mean based on what I know is is
extremely superficial
um I yeah I've read a little bit of the
top lines about people's concerns about
her associations or things that she said
or spoken on what's interesting is that
the concerns that have come from people
who say that they are conservatives are
talking about you know she part of the
globalist movement et cetera Etc
um
on the Democrat side or on the
mainstream media side the concerns they
pointed out was that she follows a lot
of conservatives on Twitter and so I
just thought it was interesting that you
have both sides finding reasons to
criticize her I don't know her I don't
know what you know what are the
qualities that that Elon Musk saw in her
to bring her on the table uh to to bring
her uh on board great let's play this
clip this is a clip of a recent
interview he did and uh his response is
just powerful go for it uh
we gotta you gotta play the question
Princess Bride
the short version doesn't have the
question in it yeah what was the
question do you remember the question
was essentially uh how concerned are you
that your personal ideology your
personal tweets your memes everything
that you do
um might affect the stock price of Tesla
uh and you know the ramifications of
that sure this is in regards to his
tweet calling George Soros Magneto
gotcha that was fact check though right
that he go ahead uh
long pause there's a scene in The
Princess Bride
powerful great movie great um
where he confronts the person who killed
his father
he says
offer me money
offer me power
I don't care
so you just don't care
if you want to share what you have to
say I also what I want to say and if if
the consequence of that is losing money
so be it
okay
no Flinch gotta love it this freaking
guy powerful yeah I mean uh look I I
hope he stays in this state there's a
lot of concerns uh I also have about
this new CEO uh but you know he ran a
poll the other day hey uh bad hire good
hire let's wait and see I think bad good
hire was six percent bad higher was like
24 and let's wait and see what's like 60
plus percent obviously the right answer
for all of us is let's wait and see
we're gonna find out what's going to
happen if she's just an advertising
person and to come from there defending
kind of BlackRock and some of that stuff
was a little bit concerning so let's
talk ESG just on that clip I just want
to say you know I think we earlier we
were talking about what what do people
value
you know that says a lot about a person
what what is most important what what
does he value obviously he's a business
guy yeah wildly successful he's good at
what he does but when it comes right
down to it what does he actually value I
learned that he values awesome movies
the princess brides I mean if you've
never seen that movie I've seen it a few
times
and what a powerful movie hundred of
giants shout out to him so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]